looking for something to play this
summer prime gaming has you covered with
a bunch of awesome free games plus
more call of duty leaks and a new kirby
title all on today's gamespot news
it's time to get your sci-fi on prime
gaming is giving away a bunch of free
titles including mass effect legendary
edition star wars jedi knight one and
two and republic commando all four of
which are some of the best sci-fi video
games of all time like seriously please
go play republic commando and then
please go and pester lucasfilm to make
another one it is so so good if that's
not your speed maybe these racing titles
will be need for speed heat and grid
legends a game that only came out a few
months ago are also included in the free
prime gaming bundle among a selection of
other titles to claim these titles you
do need a prime subscription and
everything is for the pc to see a full
list of all the games available
discounts on prime subscriptions as well
as all the other prime day deals head to
gamespot.com call of duty games just
cannot stop leaking this time for modern
warfare 2 which is releasing this 4.
while nothing has been confirmed the
images shared as a part of this new leak
have been taken down via copyright
claims the leak includes a list of kill
streaks perks field upgrades and modes
that players can expect to find in the
game many of which have been featured in
previous series entries the biggest
revelation is a variant of the massive
scale ground war mode which features 64
players duking it out on large maps with
vehicular combat the alternate version
of the mode entitled ground war bomb
will reportedly feature alongside the
standard ground war which is making its
return to call of duty for the first
time since 2019's modern warfare a full
list of all the leaked details can be
found at gamespot.com now let's talk
about a game that couldn't be further
from call of duty kirby's dream buffet
an eshop exclusive digital only game
kirby's dream buffet features colorful
round plump characters racing across
obstacle courses competing across
various rounds whoops that's the uh
that's the wrong b-roll just give me one
second
just one second guys hang on hang on
okay yep there we go as the title
suggests the levels in kirby's dream
buffet are food themed seeing which
player can gobble up the most
strawberries and using the character's
signature copy abilities to get the edge
over the competition the game doesn't
have a specific release date or price
yet but is scheduled to drop sometime
this summer and that's it for today's
gamespot news for more details on all of
the stories as well as the absolute
litany of things you can spend your
money on this prime day at amazon and
various other places please head to
gamespot.com
[Music]